في المقابل قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو ان سياسه حكومته هي منع
ايران من الحصول على سلاح النووي اضافه
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
ان اسرائيل والولايات المتحده تعمل معا
لتحقيق هذا الهدف المشترك
ا على ان هذا النظام ينبغي ان لا يملك
اسلحه نوويه انخرطنا في مفاوضات جيده
تتعلق سياسات المشتركه للتصدي لهذا الخطر
اكرر امرا سمعتموني اقوله مره عديده
سياستنا وسياستكم ان نقوم بكل ما بوسع
اسرائيل من اجل منع ايران من امتلاك سلاح
النووي والسبل التي تساعدها على ذلك نحن
والولايات المتحده نعمل معا هذا بيحدداته
امر مهم لتحقيق هذا الهدف المشترك
هذا ووصفت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه الهجوم
على مصنع العسكريين في ايران بالاستفزازي
ونقلت رويترز عن الخارجيه الروسيه قولها
ان مثل هذه التصرفات المدمره قد تكون لها
طبيعات غير متوقعه على الاستقرار والسلام
في الشرق الاوسط وقد تثير التصعيدا في وضع
ملتهب بالفعل